and everybody has a different talent and
the reason we're all so messed up is
because you're looking at everybody
else's talent everything I've ever done
has started small dunk tried to beat the
best
beat the thirst wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
everybody out every single day
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you are a genius
so today let's live your best believed
life and learn the six best lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one focus on service with Oprah
Winfrey and everybody has a different
talent and the reason we're all so
messed up is because you're looking at
everybody else's talent and wishing you
had some of their talent all the energy
that you spend thinking about wishing
about being jealous of envious of
anybody else is energy that you're not
only putting out it's going to come back
to you negatively but you're taking that
away from you all your energy should be
forced on what do I have to offer what
do I have to give how can I be used in
service because dr. King's message of
not everybody can be famous but
everybody can be great because greatness
is determined by service and there is
not a job in here that you can do that
you don't switch the paradigm to service
and not make that job more fulfilling I
don't care what the job is if you say
I'm a singer I'm a dancer I'm an artist
I'm a teacher I'm a nurse I'm a doctor
I'm a janitor I'm a clerk about if you
say if I look at this from how do I use
this in service to something bigger than
myself no longer becomes a job it
becomes an offering to the world lesson
number two generate word-of-mouth with
Elon Musk how aside from making great
products how do you get people excited
about Tesla there's a lot of people I
know and that I talked to who are just
intrigued and interested and excited
about Tesla's a company the thing that
really focus on at Tesla is like really
put all the money into an attention into
trying to make the product as compelling
as possible so
I think that really the way to sell any
product is through word-of-mouth so if a
one somebody gets the car they really
like it they and actually the key is
like to have a product that people love
and general people that if that a party
or toward friends whatever you'll talk
about the things that you love but if
you just like something it's okay you're
not gonna care that much but if you've
reactions from the highs and the lows
really I'm gonna it's you're gonna talk
you know and then that'll jarett
jarett's word of mouth and that's
basically how our sales have grown like
we don't we're not spending money on
advertising or endorsements or and so
anyone like buys a car they just water
because they they like the car and you
know it's like it's genuine lesson
number three start small with Jeff Bezos
everything I've ever done has started
small Amazon started with a couple of
people and Blue Origin started with five
people and the budget at Blue Origin was
very very small now the budgeted origins
approaches a billion dollars a year a
next year would be more than a billion
dollars in Amazon who literally was Tim
people today it's half a million people
but you it's hard to remember for you
guys but for me it's like yesterday I
was driving the packages to the post
office myself and hoping one day we
could afford a forklift and so so for me
I've seen small things get big and it's
part of this day one mentality
I like treating things as if if they're
small you know Amazon even though it is
a large company I wanted to have the
heart and spirit of a small one also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 254 series they're free the links
join are in the description below your
number one job is to become more of
yourself there are times when something
is important enough you believe it
enough that you do you do it in spite of
fear it's so
to be a small business owner in China it
took me five months to once $500 lesson
number four be the first with Jack Ma
dong tried to beat the best
be the first be the first to change be
the first the chap take the challenge be
the first one to overcome the
difficulties because the best person
there's only one Olympic champion I
don't think I'm lucky enough to be bad
but I can always try the new things and
don't give I believe it because you you
are so unique everybody's unique be
yourself is always the key lesson number
five love the game with Warren Buffett
the allowance when I was a little boy
was a nickel a week but I like the idea
of having a little more than ten
decloaking to work with then I went into
business very early they started selling
coca-cola door-to-door I sold gotten
door-to-door so Saturday in close
Liberty magazine ladies home Turley his
name it's that I think I enjoyed the
game almost right from the start but I
like being my own boss that's one thing
I liked about delivering papers I got
arranged the route I want to nobody was
bothering me at 5:00 or 6:00 in the
morning
[Music]
I was delivering 500 papers a day and I
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding is had penny surged into
something else and lesson number six the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is study success with Mark
Zuckerberg there's this culture in
Silicon Valley that kind of makes
startups seemed glamorous and I never
really believed that right I never had a
goal of starting a startup and my goal
when I realized that I had a company was
to get it to be a good company as
quickly as possible where I didn't kind
of get out of what you'd call they're
like risky startup phase where you are
just like constantly about to die and
where you can get to a point where you
can actually do some interesting things
and make make a lot of more interesting
bets and um I don't know I never read a
lot of the literature on this and I mean
maybe if I had then I wouldn't have made
so many mistakes but I don't know if
like if learning for me is the right way
to go on this but I mean but it did I
thought your model must have come from
somewhere though even if it was even if
you it was unintentional
right like were you influenced by Peter
Thiel where Sean well yes people say all
these people once I met them I actually
I hadn't really heard of Peter Thiel
before I'm talking about yeah right yeah
he was massively influential on my
thinking right I mean I like a lot of
the the early lessons that I took on how
to think about strategy came from Peter
and Sean and I did pay a lot of
attention when I was growing up to
Microsoft I thought I mean I grew up you
know using you know Windows 3.1 and then
windows 95 and I just thought that those
were like the most unbelievable things
and since they are yeah they really
really were awesome right well I don't
know if you you meant that positive
positively but I did and and I thought
you know building this ecosystem was
really neat and that kind of inspired me
right in the way that they built a
platform I kind of thought okay well
maybe one day you know that the tools
that I'm building can be part of a
broader ecosystem as well now I have a
special bonus clip with Sara Blakely on
how to ask questions that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action
here we go watch number one which three
people will you study there success from
this week number two how can you focus
on serving someone today number three
what's one small start that you can do
right now and if you're going to take
immediate action after watching this
video give me a hash tag believe down in
the comments as well many aspiring
entrepreneurs even in this room struggle
to find their initial idea how do you
constantly find ways to invent new
products and where does your inspiration
come from you know I I mean I think of a
lot of ideas at traffic lights I think
of them all the time in different places
and I think it's part of just being
hyper observant I I like to find white
space I pay attention to what are things
that haven't evolved and why you know
like there's certain things in our
society that updates itself and changes
and and you know constantly and then
there's certain things that it's not and
so I'll ask myself questions all day
every day it's just the way my brain
works like I could even be looking at a
table and be like why is the table like
that
when was the table first created is that
the actual best design for a table or
could there be something different and
you know what Spanx went into men's and
that was randomly how that happened was
because I got curious that the man's
undershirt was created in 1918 and no
one had paid any attention to it since
it was literally the same thing and so I
just you know talked to my brother and
my husband about it and their
undershirts that the neck stretched out
or they were boxy and bulky under
clothes and I thought oh I'm just gonna
add a little bit of like or to the
cotton undershirt for men and so the
neck won't stretch out I'm gonna taper
it in at the waist so ideas come to me
like that ideas I really hope clearly I
love I have my assistant who's my right
hand lisa is she's been my right hand
for 16 years can attest to this but I
have 99 pages I don't know why it's 99
but it she told me the other day it's 99
pages single spaced typed of ideas
one more idea so ie I think of ideas
constantly on airplanes in car you know
talking to somebody and I email it to
myself and then I just keep them and
logged them
if you want to learn more lessons from
Elon Musk Warren Buffett and other
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
if you want to be successful learn from
the other people's mistakes don't learn
from the successful stories